hi there my name is Kevin and I usually
make videos over on my channel where I
show you guys how to make the web and
how to make it look good while you're at
it with a new video every single week I
was super kindly asked to make a collab
video so I'm really excited me making a
video over here today and what we're
going to be doing is we're gonna be
exploring the CSS grid so right here
right now you should see a little thing
going by that's showing you what we're
going to be building it's a really
simple layout but it should it works
really really well and basically it's
using the grid lets us cut down on our
markup and it also lets us cut down on
our media queries I have to really small
simple media queries to make this work
it's amazing how easy it is to do this
even the CSS is a lot shorter of
something like this if you'd want to try
and do it with flexbox so it's really
really fun and cool we're gonna be
looking at something called min max for
setting some widths or else gonna be
looking at the autofill and how we can
use it in a repeat thing for the grid
template columns and it just makes
everything work it's really really cool
and really really fun so instead of
talking about it let me show you guys
how we're actually gonna do that alright
so here we are in code pen so the link
for this will be down below and there
will actually be two links one of them
will be to the starting point where we
are right now
and the second one will be to the
finished version of this so you can
either follow along with me with the
starting point one or you can just skip
ahead all the way to the finished one to
get some ideas and see how I did stuff
from there or if you get stuck when
you're following along you can always
refer to that code as you can see the
starting point one I do have some stuff
on here already I really want to make
this a focus on how the grid works so
I've already laid out some stuff and
we're just right now it's not really
working too good we're getting these
giant pictures and we want to fix this
and make it look good at using the grid
or just really quickly I'm going to look
through the mark-up that I've already
done so here there is an art team
section which is just giving us this
background here and in there I have a
grid container the only thing the grid
container is currently doing is acting
it has a max width set on it and it's
centering stuff that we're going to be
adding some stuff in there shortly I
have this description thing here so this
is just a div team description it has a
title div and then a paragraph in it and
then all of these things here are made
with these figures so I
using figures whenever I have this sort
of hover effect like this what I'm doing
is I have the figure which is keeping
everything together it lets the browser
know that all of this image and this h2
are related to one another and you could
of course put a little paragraph or some
other text in here as well I'm just
using some fill Marie filler things
right now just we have a picture of a
person it would look a little better if
everybody was different but the code pen
and you know it's easier to do it like
this yeah so there I think it's pretty
straightforward I have my image and then
my figcaption really quickly Alyssa's
dive into my CSS I don't want to look at
it too much I am using sass for this if
you're not familiar with sass I will
look at a few things but if ever there's
something that's confusing you and
you're looking at the code pin you can
always do view compiled CSS and you're
gonna see what the actual version looks
like but I'm not doing anything too
in-depth with sass I'm just a little bit
of basic stuff with it so one thing I
will be using are some of these
variables here I do have my box sizing
and border box just to make my life a
little bit easier our team so this is
just some basic styling where it comes
to this little hover effect that I have
I just have a position:relative for the
team member which is my whole figure my
image is set to a width of a hundred
percent just to make sure it's matching
the size of the entire figure
and then my figcaption which is this
thing that shows up is a
position:absolute my top bottom left and
right or set up just to keep this little
space right there it has a background of
color using display flex on it so a lot
of people think well we're using the
grid now I don't need flex anymore but
flex still has a purpose it still does a
lot of things I use it for all my
smaller components and little things
like that so I'm just using this to
align the text vertically and
horizontally in the middle and I've had
the opacity set to zero and then I
transition so when I'm hovering on top
of my figcaption sorry know when I'm
hovering on top of my team member the
figcaption of that team members opacity
will switch over to one so that's why
it's working like that so with all that
out of the way let's get to the
nitty-gritty of this and start dealing
with some grid stuff so right away I
find these pictures are too big so I'm
gonna come on to my grid container here
I
that grid container because I want to be
using a grid on it ma'am and I mentioned
there's not too much going on so the
very first thing we're going to do is
we're gonna come here and just do
display grid and it's not really gonna
change anything if you're doing this on
your own file it's a little bit of a
different design it is possible that
there's a small change in it just
because the collapsing margins will no
longer collapse the same as flexbox when
as soon as you put on the display grid
the next thing I'm going to do is let's
just set up a couple of columns so the
reason nothing changed is the way it's
working with the grid is it's keeping
the one column the whole way here and
it's just filling automatically adding
rows in there which is exactly how block
level elements are already working we
have a column of one bunch of one big
column and then we get a whole bunch of
rows in there so just to show you that
this is actually working we can do the
grid Auto flow and right now this is one
it's Auto flowing rows so it's
automatically creating rows for my
content I could switch that over and
tell it to Auto make columns instead so
it's gonna keep everything in one row
and automatically create a new column
for each thing and then we get this
really weird result you might want to
use that in some projects but in this
one I'm not gonna be doing that what
we're gonna do instead is we're gonna
use a grid template column so an into a
grid template column I could give it
some specific values let's say I want
100 to be kind of small let's go to 200
maybe 200 pixels 200 pixels and that's
gonna give me two columns of 200 with
grid template columns it's plural and so
I have two columns there each 200 pixels
wide and not perfect not exactly what
we're after it's causing some issues and
stuff but at least we have two columns
and just to show you if you wanted three
I could come up and make it three just
by adding another one there and now I
have three columns if you're gonna do
something like that you can also make
your life a little bit easier and they
don't all have to be the same just
really quickly I could make this first
one 500 if I wanted to so I have 500 and
then 200 and 200 but if they're all
gonna be the same you can do something
linked repeat 3
200 pixels and now I have three columns
of 200 pixels so it just makes it a
little bit faster to write and if I
wanted to change it it's really easy to
change and if you are using the repeat
thing you can still have something
before it so I have one column of 500
followed by two columns of 200 on the
side now obviously this isn't exactly
what we want so I'm going to go back to
two columns for now the other thing
that's cool with this is there is a new
unit called the FR which is a fraction
so I'm gonna do repeat two so I have two
columns of one fr and when fr just means
take up all the available space in this
case it means there's two columns and
they're just 50% cuz there's 50% space
available to both of them if I made just
really quick just to give an idea of how
this fr is working I could do say one fr
two fr and again it's available space so
it really depends as there's when
they're small small small it's going to
be a little bit different but as there's
more space available this one would be
twice as big as that one but it's not at
all what we want so let's go back to
this so they're all equal now the one
problem I have I have a few actually I
have this small little gap that's
showing up under all my pictures I'm
gonna go down to my images here and I'm
just gonna say that these are a display
block if ever you've had that problem
before it's because images are inline
block so they're trying to line up at
the bottom of the text the text has the
little descenders here that say this p
like drops below the main line of the
text so that gap there is to take into
account and give those room to live we
want to get rid of that so I'm just
going to switch to that to display block
so now one problem is they're all stuck
together and I don't want them being
stuck together so I'm gonna come up and
say grid gap and I'll put one em and
this is amazing I love the grid gap it's
one of the coolest things for the grid
for me there's lots of really awesome
stuff but if ever you've made a column
system using either floats or flexbox
you'll know you know so you have six
columns the first column you can't have
any extra space on the left of it the
last column can't have the extra space
on the right of it and you sort of have
to take all of that into account
and add a few extra lines of CSS to take
that into account and now you don't have
to worry about it this just works like
magic you can also control them
separately on the columns and the rows
so I can do grid column gap of 1m and
then it's only gonna be on my column so
there's no space between my rows or I
can do my grid row gap and then I only
up the space on my rows and not my
columns and the shorthand is grid gap so
it's doing both of them and I believe
you can also do something like that so
it's going to be my rows and then my
columns superduper so that's looking
pretty good for the small screen sizes I
think that's gonna be perfect that's not
what we're after I can tell you what's
happening here because they're using the
fr and the fr again is the available
space so what's happening is because
this team the word team here can't get
smaller than that so as soon as this is
taking up there's no more available
space this is as small as this column
can get well the other column has to get
smaller to take into account this not
being able to get smaller so this is
always available space so it doesn't
mean that they're equal it means that if
there is extra space they're
distributing the extra space equally
between the two so that is really an
important distinction to make
now we're gonna fix this little weird
thing going on by going and I don't have
a selector for it I want to take this
whole team description thing so we're
gonna do dot team description and I'm
gonna say on this that the we want it to
cross both columns so I'm gonna say grid
column span too so I'm telling it to go
across both columns span across my two
columns so now the only time this is
really gonna start coming into it as a
bigger issue is here but my screen is so
small we never that you know we're at
like 200 pixels or something so nobody's
really gonna be getting that tiny and
otherwise it should work pretty good and
overall I mean now the pictures are
getting way too big but hey it's working
right so if you want to end there you
could but we can do a lot better than
just this so what I'm thinking is when
I'm getting up to a certain screen size
here what I want to happen
is these start getting kind of big so I
want to actually jump over to doing
three columns instead of having just two
columns so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna add in a media query we're gonna
keep the media queries as simple as
possible but just to show you and give
you an idea of what I want to be doing
let's come here and if you're not used
to SAS I'm actually put my media query
inside my grid container which would be
the same as coming down here and doing
at media and writing out the whole media
query but if I do it inside it's just
going to automatically do it only for my
grid container so at media we'll look at
the compiled CSS in a second so I'm
gonna say at media and we're gonna come
in here with a min width of 50 M 50 m I
like putting em so you can actually be a
little bit more consistent between
browsers and and other stuff if you use
M s instead of pixels or REMS so you
just have to multiply by 16 and you know
you get a few numbers that get soaking
ahead so this I believe is 800 pixels so
when we get to a width of 800 pixels
we're going to do a grid template
columns and we're going to change it so
I'm going to do a repeat 3 fr and we're
gonna change
whoops of one fr so that should change
us over to three columns and we get this
this is kind of weird now but it's at
least my pictures aren't getting too big
is right as they start getting to that
point where they're too big we're on
three columns but now there's a problem
is it's gonna get the same thing now so
now you know they get kind of big again
and I'd rather this is four columns now
I don't want to build another media
query for that and we don't have to this
is one of my favorite favorite things
with the grid template columns so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna keep my repeat
there but instead of saying three I'm
gonna put Auto fit and what this is
gonna do is it's gonna auto fit now if I
just leave it like that it's actually
gonna stay - because they can stay - so
what auto fit is going to do is it's
gonna look at how big we want it so
let's just say we put 300 pixels here it
means that it's gonna get so you can see
now it has two columns and this is
stopping after two columns and then it's
gonna go oh now I have room for three
columns so I'm gonna make three columns
and oh now we
got there let's do 200 then so now we'll
see it now so we're 2 and then oh we
have room for three oh I got room for
four oh I got room for five so it's
gonna automatically make new columns as
long as there's room for them but having
something like 200 pixels sucks cuz it
doesn't it's not really responsive it's
just like sort of click click click mmm
it doesn't look so great and so we're
gonna add in another really cool thing
which is the min max so min max is
really cool because you can give it a
minimum width and a maximum width so my
minimum width that I'm gonna give it is
15 m and 15 M comes out to about 240
pixels I think so I want to give it a
minimum size of around 240 pixels and I
want to give it a maximum size of 1fr
now one mistake some people make is they
put the 1fr as the minimum and then say
like 2fr is the maximum you can't
actually have an fr as a minimum size it
just won't work then it needs to be a
unit like something that has a
measurable size to it whereas the fr is
an abstract unit it's just use the
available space whatever is available so
that can definitely be a maximum but it
can't be a minimum so just be careful
you have to give it an actual value for
your minimum so now what we're gonna see
is when I'm so we're gonna go to here
and then when I get to my 800 pixels Oh
so I'm gonna I have room for three of
them at 240 pixel width or 15 mm width
and well I don't have room to create a
new row so I don't have there's not an
extra 240 pixels or 15m here on the side
so I'm just gonna keep filling these to
use the available space I'm gonna keep
filming them they're gonna keep getting
a little bigger a little bigger and then
oh I actually have room for 4 of them
now at this width so because I have 4
room for 4 of them I'm gonna make 4
columns and then we're gonna do the same
thing all over again
and then at this point it's going to
stop because that's the max size of my
container so that's a really cool thing
you we could actually build this into
here but then we just you'd still run
into some issues at the really small
screen sizes just because of the way the
min/max works so I just felt it was a
bit better to do it this way
so this is kind of weird still so we
still have a few little things we want
to fix and when I get to here I don't
really like how this looks so right now
we're running into mostly issues here
and here but we're getting pretty close
to what we want to be doing so what
we're gonna do now is here I don't
actually want this to spend two anymore
I could have it spent three and then
this we know we'd have are all six team
members on the end but we might as well
make this a little bit more dynamic so
what I'm gonna do is let's come down to
the description here and let's change
how this is going to behave so I'm going
to do my @media
and what we're gonna do on this one so
we'll do the same thing we're gonna do a
min with 50m and I'm gonna say now that
I'm gonna do my grid column is gonna go
back to auto so Auto just means be as
you were before so it's only taking up
one column now Auto will just it's the
same as doing like a initial that's just
the default so it goes there and then oh
that's kind of weird we have a little
middle zone so maybe I'll change this in
a second where the breakpoint is but
we'll get there in a second so we get to
here and then that looks okay but now we
have this weird problem of these being
really tall because they're trying to
fit all the text so what I'm gonna do is
we're gonna say that the grid Row is a
span to now so we're saying we're
telling this that you should be taking
up two rows and now it sort of lets
everything else flow into it properly
and we just have a little bit of empty
space down here on the bottom and then
here it actually worked really well
right now so this is sort of where I
want to be at the end this looks pretty
good my main issue is this big big empty
space that we're ending up with down
here and the reason we're getting this
big empty space is well the text is just
stopping two rows is taking up all this
room so what we can also do on here is
and if you're used to flexbox you'll be
familiar with this is a line self so I
can do an end on this and it would push
it all the way down to the bottom or we
can do a center and just vertically
Center it right in the middle and it
just balances the whole thing out really
really nicely so there we go I think
that looks really nice and then even
that works too because it keeps it
balanced with everything else it's nice
and vertically centered and then we get
this a nice team section here we get
this a nice thing where it sort of wraps
around I find it looks more dynamic and
it's something that we wouldn't have
really been able to do a flexbox is
we're using flexbox we'd probably need
to actually keep all of these sort of
held together maybe you'd like that
better you you know we can have this
here and this would be more of a big
thing that I could just fix that by
changing this over to a span three if I
really wanted to and then I would have
that where it looks like that it you
know and then I'd get the same thing
going on so if you don't like the look
of it wrapping underneath and you'd
rather you can just switch that over to
a span three but personally I sort of
like this dynamic look and feel where
they're wrapping underneath like that we
do have to fix this
oh you know what it's a really small
area it's kind of weird that it's
breaking and breaking that's a see we
have like the smallest thing there hmm
if I just did like 48 instead why is
that happening
so here we're okay we get to 50m we're
going to our autofit oh it's because
this is a minimum with the 50mm and I
have a feeling what's happening is let's
just change this to like a 55 maybe it's
gonna that should avoid it yeah so what
was happening is even though I was
putting this in at 50 it still couldn't
fit three next to each other um so it
was giving us that really weird super
small break point actually I'll bring
that down to like a fifty two let's just
try that again yeah there we go so
that's gonna work better and that's
about it and oh just really quickly if
you want to see again view compiled CSS
so I have my grid container I have all
my stuff on there and then I just have
an app media and then the grid container
inside of that so that's the what's
going on it just I find it a lot easier
to write things with the media query
inside especially if you
multiple media queries or something
anyway that's a bit beside the point for
the moment so yeah that's it and let's
just look at it one more time make sure
it's working properly and yeah it looks
really good
I'm really happy with this I hope you're
really happy with this I hope you can
find a way to use this on your project
and I hope you understand the grid a
little bit more using and trying to you
take advantage of this autofit it can
really do some really cool things and
definitely eliminates the needs for some
media queries you're never gonna get rid
of all your media queries but you can
definitely get rid of some of your media
queries with things like this and just
in case you're asking I'm just gonna
take this and plug it in right there
just to show you what could happen and
this is the problem that we're getting
into it's the same problem we had before
where these are getting smaller and it's
the reason that I didn't have this on
from the very beginning and the reason
that I can't do it is because it's once
we get to here we gave it a minimum size
of 15 so what's actually happening is
it's it's wanting to only have one
column so it's creating only one column
by default but we're telling this it has
to spend two columns so it's forcing a
second column in there even though this
is only trying to make one column so the
second column is sort of like an
implicit column that's not following
these rules and it's this weird little
buggy thing that sometimes that the grid
can be kind of annoying but it's because
this is spanning two and I'm forcing it
to spend two that it's sort of
conflicting with what this is trying to
do so either I could use this the whole
way across and I could just build
another media query into this one and
that would work so I'm I spent to only
starts at a smaller screen size or we
just do it like this where it starts off
I have my two columns and then it builds
out from there so either way would give
you the same result in the end all right
so I hope you liked that video if you
did like it please hit the thumbs up
also leave a comment down below to let
me know you liked it if you liked this
as I mentioned at the beginning I have
my own channel where I do this every
single week so the there's the name of
coming up on the screen now and you can
also go down to the description below
and follow a link over will bring you to
my channel thank you so much for
watching once again I really hope you
liked it and if you have any questions
any comments leave them down below I'll
gladly respond to them and yeah until
next time don't forget to make your
quantum a internet just a little bit
more awesome